home les jeunes et l'amour ou souvenez
jérôme c'est le thème que nous allons
développer tout au long de cette semaine
avec une enquête menée par la jeune
catherine ceylac et le non moins jeune
bruno gex à partir d'un sondage exclusif
réalisé par l'institut csa de roland
cayrol pour le compte de ces la vie et
du parisien oui là sachez tout d'abord
que depuis quelques années via sur les
tabous ont volé en éclats mais cette
liberté sexuelle ne conduit pas les
jeunes à s'éclater à tout crin non ils
ont le sens de la mesure et sont attirés
par un amour durable et c'est ce que
révèle dans ce sondage parisien c'est la
vie c'est pourquoi une cherchent à
bloquer le rédacteur en chef du journal
est avec nous pour nous apporter un
petit peu ses commentaires à ses
observations un sondage qui a été
commandé à l'institut de sondages csa
auprès de 668 jeunes de 13 à 19 ans qui
ont été interrogés pour savoir donc
comment ils vivaient l'amour dans le
présent et surtout comment ils le
voyaient dans le futur ils sont amoureux
pour plus de la moitié d'entre eux et
croit à l'amour avec un grand a
seulement 5% pensent qu'une fille doit
rester vierge jusqu'au mariage
il y a dix ans ils étaient 21 % mais
plus de la moitié considère qu'une fille
doit être vierge jusqu'à une rencontre
avec un garçon qu'elle aime vraiment
sexe oui mais avec sentiments
les filles sont séduites par les garçons
qui ont de l'humour mais elle ne néglige
pas leur physique
les garçons choisiront une fille pour
son physique pour la moitié d'entre eux
après seulement intervient son humour
son intelligence son look à la question
avec qui elle joue le plus à l'aise pour
parler de sexualité les copains et
copines arrive en tête suivie de très
très très loin des parents 84 % d'entre
eux disent ne pas avoir changé de
comportement sexuel à cause du sida
il accorde beaucoup d'importance à la
fidélité et veulent pouvoir avoir
confiance en l'autre
le mariage n'est plus une finalité 69 %
sont d'accord pour dire qu'un homme et
une femme vivant ensemble ne doivent pas
forcément se marier en 1976 ils étaient
46%
si le mariage a du plomb dans l aile les
enfants on demeure une valeur sûre
ils sont 87% en souhaité voilà qui
devrait rassurer les démographes